all right people how are you it's march
16 2022.
i am dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message and we are live
streaming on rumble youtube and blaze tv
share subscribe tap things etc
and today i am making two major
announcements so the show is going to be
a little bit different today we are
going to focus on two announcements uh
one of them professional one of them
personal i suspect that some of you
have already guessed at least one of
them i don't suspect it i know it
because i see comments in the locals
community and you are wise wise people
who have picked up on the hints that i
have been dropping so yes two
announcements today
uh the professional one sort of pretty
straightforward the personal one will be
a little more personal and heartfelt uh
we're gonna get to both of them uh
before we do any of that though i guess
it's sort of connected in some ways i've
got a book coming out have you heard
about this thing don't burn this country
comes out on april 12
2022 you can pre-order right now at
daverubin.combook
and you can order from barnes noble or
amazon or your local bookstore all the
links are there so you can see what's
what so that actually is the perfect
segue to announcement one which is the
professional announcement again we got a
professional one
and a personal one oh and i should say
before we go any further
uh a lot of you were very excited about
uh darlene yesterday darlene who showed
up on the view my little impression
there that i did on the view very
exciting people are going crazy went out
with a friend last night to dinner as
i'm walking out of the restaurant a
young girl runs up to me and said dave i
loved you on the view yesterday so we're
we're doing good things around here i'm
feeling good about life it's all good so
let's talk about announcement number one
the the professional announcement so yes
the book is coming out i'm super psyched
as i told you guys i uh just recorded
the audiobook it's fun it's heartfelt
it's humorous it's
painful
it's the whole damn thing and it's
extremely relevant to everything going
on in the world but the announcement is
that the tour the don't burn this
country tour
uh the tickets are about to go on sale
we're doing a pre-sale tomorrow for
locals community members so if you join
it
reubenreport.locals.com you guys are
going to get the first batch of tickets
you will have access to the first batch
and then the general public as we call
it in the industry the general public
will be able to get tickets on friday so
why don't we throw that image up on
there let's talk about where we're going
to be going and why we're going places
and uh i should tell you guys that this
is just
the first leg of the tour we're trying
to figure out where i want to go when i
want to be there and i think when i tell
you the second announcement today you'll
understand a little bit uh sort of
limits on my time and things of that
nature so we're starting this thing on
april 18th in orlando florida it's a
huge theater about 900 people uh hope to
see you guys at the plaza live i wanted
to start
in florida we thought originally we were
going to start in miami uh and we're
going to do some other meet and greet
kind of stuff in miami and obviously i'm
here in miami and it'll be a little
easier to do so we wanted to bounce
around through some other places in
florida so we are starting in orlando of
course orlando the home of disney and uh
disney just tried to smack down ron
desantis didn't work out as uh disney
would have liked but hopefully there are
some sane people in orlando i know there
are i did the natcon event there a few
months ago there's a lot of great people
in orlando i dig orlando you know
sometimes orlando gets a bit of a bad
rap
you know north
landlocked etc i like orlando i'm
looking forward to going there and i
think that's the biggest theater of the
entire tour uh april 19th we will be in
west palm beach florida that is a
conservative stronghold donald trump
country who mar-a-lago et cetera we're
going to be at the palm beach
improv by the way i really uh am going
to try to do this tour in a in a really
new
and sort of novel way you know obviously
i toured with jordan peterson and i
always tell you guys you know he would
give these different hour and a half
lectures every night and sometimes he
would talk about the book sometimes he
would talk about 12 rules sometimes he
would talk about one rule sometimes he
wouldn't talk about the book at all
sometimes he would talk about a twitter
fight he got into that day sometimes he
would talk about hippies it was really
sort of all over the place but i love to
you know like an hour before the show
just sort of see the direction that he
was kind of going in and where he was
gonna go and then and then i'd poke and
prod him a little bit with the q a
um so i'm gonna really try to do this
tour like every single show will be
different if you come
to more than one show you will see a
completely
different show it's gonna sort of be
what's on my mind that day it's
obviously gonna be couched a little bit
around the book at least some some shows
maybe i'll just do like hey here are the
nine chapters let's run let's run the
gamut uh but it's going to be different
it's going to be fun and you know i'll
mess with the crowd and i think you're
going to dig it people april 20th i am
going to be in clearwater florida at the
capitol theater uh april 21st will
escape
well it's not escape there's no escaping
florida we will sadly leave florida for
a few days go to raleigh north carolina
at the raleigh improv then over to
atlanta georgia center stage and
actually come back to me for a sec
because i do want to reiterate something
that i said a while back and it caused a
lot of consternation with my people
which is that i had said from beat one i
was not going to do any shows where
there were mask mandates or where there
were vaccine passports or anything you
are welcome to come to my show and you
if you want to wear something on your
face you can if you would like to show
someone a passport you can but it's not
going to be requested uh i don't want
anything to do with any of that so all
of these theaters are allowing this at
the moment uh unfortunately we live in
this bizarre time where i suppose
anything can change at any given second
and it does seem like covid 2 is on the
way but i have a feeling they're going
to hold off that season of covet to a
little bit right before the midterm
elections maybe so that they can uh get
us all to mail in ballot you sort of see
what they do here so i have a feeling
we're going to be okay on the covet
front
because there were some concerns in
atlanta that was one of the places uh
that they thought maybe there were going
to be mass mandates etc etc but it looks
like everything's going away so 100 i'm
not performing at a place i'm not
showing up to a city or a venue where
there are mask mandates or anything else
again it's fine if you want to do it in
your personal life it really is i'm just
not participating that by the way we're
also doing meet and greets for all of
these i will shake your hands
limited amount of hugs per show and uh
and i'll get to see you and sign some
books
and uh take selfies and and the whole
damn thing so that's april 22nd in
atlanta georgia at center stage then
we're heading to chicago hopefully i
don't get shot
that's it
that's april 23rd chicago illinois
improv chicago maybe i could get lori
lightfoot to open for me in chicago
that's what i should be doing as i'm
talking about this i get who will open
for me in each one of these shows we'll
probably have some surprise guests we'll
get some people see what things are
doing but imagine if i get laurie
lightfoot out there to open up for me
man beetlejuice right up there on stage
to perform and make you people laugh
bring me out there that would be good
then we're jumping over to dallas texas
this is the only texas stop in the in
this initial leg again this is just the
initial leg uh dallas you know maybe i
can get my buddy glenn beck to swing by
i'll i'll text him in a little bit maybe
he'll come by and do a little do a
little q a with me that'll be at the
south side music hall and then yeah we
are going to add some dallas stop some
other texas stops uh that was one of the
major ones i was pushing for so we will
make all that happen but that's a quick
one april 24th dallas texas south side
music hall april 25th
washington d.c that's right we're going
to that wretched hive of scum and
villainy the miracle theater i will be
there dc you know the funny thing about
dc
is before kovid i i've said this to you
guys many times i love loved dc i loved
going there from the first time i went
when i was probably in third grade when
we took a family trip to dc and and
walking from the the washington monument
to the lincoln memorial and i love the
jefferson memorial which is a little off
the beaten path and going to
washington's home and and going to
arlington cemetery like i just love the
history i've always loved all of it i
love
uh i love just like the buildings and
this it's all just like man there was
something really good here in america dc
sort of ain't that right now um but i'm
really looking forward i did the dc
improv couple years back was awesome
sold out show great energy and there's a
lot of good people in the dc area if if
it's not all swamp creatures just living
in dc uh i know there's plenty of good
people obviously the maryland areas over
there and baltimore et cetera et cetera
so washington dc april 25th the miracle
theater then we're jumping up to new
york my home state the state i was born
in they're letting me back in
west nyack we're going to be at the
levity live comedy club that's april
26th uh i believe west nile is that
westchester technically can you find out
is west nyack technically in westchester
i thought we could do something you know
i'm a long island guy originally i
thought we could do long island didn't
didn't work out for this immediate thing
because again it was all very up in the
air because of the masks and the
freaking
passports and everything else i think
west nyack is part of westchester if i'm
not mistaken you do a little research
for me would you do that but i'm looking
forward to that uh then then we have a
little bit of a break so that's april
26th then we have a little bit of a
break where maybe we'll add a couple
things i'm not sure but i do want to get
home for some things i also want to you
know i love doing this show and i don't
want to yes i'm being told
wes nayak is in westchester okay i get
some kind of award for that um
i love doing the show and i don't want
to be on the road that was really one of
my calculations it's like i don't want
to miss daily shows all the time we'll
figure out some ways to to shoot some
stuff on the road and all that kind of
stuff but i do want to get back here in
studio so we have that little break
between that show and then i head to
the state of california that's right i
will be at the brea improv on may 11th i
did a show there a couple years back
also sold out great crowd uh i know it's
just like a really good group of people
in that area so that's may 11th uh brea
california improv brea or improv as it
were uh the next night i'll be in oxnard
california at oxnard levity live which i
also did a show uh sold out show over
there uh and then finally uh the last
two for this initial leg is it the last
one or the last two or no last two or
three see we added something okay uh may
15 san jose california which is a great
club too the improv san jose i did that
it's actually more of like a theater
than a comedy club they got a nice
mezzanine and you can
you know maybe throw some things at me
don't i don't recommend doing that but
it's a great club over there in san jose
uh and then the final two on this last
leg if i'm not mistaken i think yeah
final two
phoenix arizona i will uh be willing to
go into the dry heat as they say uh and
that's the tempe improv which i also did
a show there which was awesome a couple
years back when i was when i was doing
the tour but with jordan and i would
just have an off night uh i would just
go to these comedy clubs and do my thing
and then finally the the last show that
we're announcing right now for the
initial leg of the tour
denver colorado you can get stoned and
come see me at the gothic theater on may
18th
and uh very exciting stuff people so uh
as i said the pre-sale tickets will go
on sale tomorrow we're gonna have a
private link in the reuben report
community so the locals community
members are able to purchase tickets
first that you know membership has its
privileges as they say uh you can join
right now if you want at
reubenreport.locals.com you'll have
access to all these tickets and it's uh
10 a.m
eastern everything goes on sale 10 a.m
local time tomorrow whatever your local
time is
in your city and state uh the tickets
will go on sale we'll have all the links
there and then tickets go on sale to the
general public on friday and i'm psyched
to just get out there again and see
people again and
you know it's one of the reasons that
living here in florida has been so
fantastic just to be out and about and
see people go out to dinner shake hands
and just reconnect with humans which in
some ways is very much what the book is
about like how do we fix
so much of this craziness right now this
disconnect we have with our neighbors
and our family and everything else like
the book is in some ways trying to
trying to repair that like we need a
sense of community not a sense of
collectiveness which is uh
collectivism which is really what we're
being pushed what's being pushed on us
all the time but we need a sense of
community so i'm really psyched to get
out there and maybe we'll ask people to
dress up a little bit nicer what do you
think i think so why not i'm gonna dress
up nice i'll dress up you know something
like this maybe i'll put on a tie for
some of the shows and what if you people
dressed up to go out to a theater or
even to a comedy club and like we make
it something you know that was one of
the great things about jordan's tour and
jordan stores going on right now uh like
that people are like oh this is i'm
doing something and i'm gonna see other
people who are you know standing up
straight with their shoulders back out
on the town to have a good time and all
that good stuff okay so that's it for
the book that's the personal uh that's
the pro
that's a professional announcement uh
and uh now i want to talk to you about
the personal announcement which actually
is much bigger than anything sort of
career-wise or anything else
but before i do that people i want to
talk to you about expressvpn does it
make sense that the same company who
controls half of online retail also
passively eavesdrops on your private
conversations at home what about the
idea that a single company controls 90
of your internet searches runs your
email service and gets to track
everything you do on your smartphone big
tech is more powerful than most
countries are and they are profiting by
exploiting your personal data it's time
to put a layer of protection between
your online activity and these tech
juggernauts and that's why i use
expressvpn think about how much of your
life is on the internet sadly every site
you visit video you watch or message you
send gets tracked and data mined but
when you run expressvpn on your device
the software hides your ip address
something big tech can use to personally
identify you so expressvpn makes your
activity harder to trace and sell to
advertisers it also encrypts 100 of your
internet data to keep you safe from
hackers and eavesdroppers on your
network and it does all of this without
slowing your connection that's why
expressvpn is rated number one by the vp
rated number one vpn service by mashable
and techradar download the app on your
phone or computer tap one button and
you're good to go so stop handing over
your personal data to big tech
monopolies that mine your activity and
sell your info protect yourself with the
vpn i trust to keep you safe online
visit
expressvpn.com and that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n dot com slash reuben
to get three extra months free go to
expressvpn.com
reuben right now to learn more okay
all right so here's the really big
announcement and this is the personal
one and the life-changing one and the
whole thing and i i know that a lot of
you have uh been asking me about this
and uh you know when i wrote
the original book don't burn this book
which at this point came out two years
ago which is crazy so i really wrote it
three years ago
and and even a year before that four
years ago was when david and i really
started talking about expanding our
family
it's something that we've been thinking
about weighing the pros and cons what
are we going to do you know i've sort of
for the first 40 years of my life i kind
of just didn't think i would have kids
or i could just do whatever i wanted or
something like that it just wasn't
really
something that i really thought about
that much and in a weird way i guess the
gay thing kind of gives you like an easy
out on that because uh
i'm not a scientician but it's hard for
two biological men or two biological
women to actually reproduce without some
help so it was sort of felt like an easy
off-ramp or something like that um but
david you know we've been together for
like 13 years at this point which in
straight years is like 40 years you know
that's that's how the conversion rate
works on that thing uh we got married in
the summer of 2015 so we've been married
about seven years but we've been
together about 13 years overall and um
he's a little bit younger than me so he
grew up in a time when when it was just
obvious that oh you could be gay and
have a family and be somewhat normal i
don't like that word normal but like you
could have you could have something
normal
um and and something conventional as
boring as that may sound to some degree
where i grew up you know when i grew up
it was like there was nobody talking
about any of this stuff like there was
no like oh that's a
those are two dads or those are two moms
and that's a family or something like
that i didn't know anyone like that i
just never thought about it it just and
also i put so much into my career that
for better or worse i think it obviously
helped me accomplish a lot in some ways
but i was so focused and driven that i
that it's a miracle in some ways that i
found someone to marry but it's also
kind of a miracle that
now we can move on to this uh to this
next phase so
yes
uh
we are expanding the family
uh but you know i have a belief that
when you do things uh you don't just go
you go big
so uh two babies people
two babies are on the way uh those are
ultrasounds what you're seeing over
there
uh
yeah so okay this is going to be very
confusing to people and i understand
this right like okay wait a minute
you're both dudes you're showing me two
ultrasounds they don't look exactly the
same what's going on there are they
twins are they something else can we we
pull those images up again one of them
seems lighter than the other what is
there a coloration problem what's going
on here is this racial i get it there's
a lot of questions related to all of
this so let me just back up a little bit
and tell you about our sort of fertility
journey so it look when you have two men
or two women you're missing a piece
right you got the sperm
or you got the egg but you don't have a
sperm and an egg right you don't have a
womb you got to figure out some things
here
um and you know by the way i know most
of you guys that are watching this are
now on more conservative side of things
and i never see any real issue with
conservatives anymore and gay people and
trump was the first you know
first time president to run being you
know pro-gay marriage and i think most
people just kind of want to live and let
live and all that but i know this is
like a little bit weird for some people
to hear right i get it and by the way to
me at some level this is a little bit
weird like i've had to learn a lot of
stuff and go to a lot of doctors and
it's and it's cost a lot of money and
it's been a long
sort of adventure but basically what
you're seeing there one more time with
those ultrasounds would you uh those are
two different wombs and those are two
different babies um and i now i now know
an awful lot about
uh birth and i know an awful lot about
zygotes and i know an awful lot about
wombs and days when things start
happening and heartbeat appointments and
all kinds of stuff so basically what we
are doing
is we got one egg donor so you got to
think about this if you need to stop
right now and grab a sharpie and make a
chart uh you could uh so basically we've
got plenty of sperm around here that's
that's one thing right so there's a lot
this i'm just saying there's a lot of
sperm we didn't have a shortage of sperm
so we've got sperm so we had half the
battle right we had half of what we
needed but we needed an egg so there are
egg donors that are out there these are
young women who are willing to donate
their eggs women and women obviously
make a lot of eggs
some make a lot of eggs some don't make
eggs but the donors usually are young
and healthy and and if they want to help
people that otherwise can't have
children they can donate their eggs so
you basically
go on all of these websites there are
all these sites and it's sort of like
tinder or whatever app you were dating
on where you're just kind of swiping
through people and you say oh i like the
way she looks or i like this girl had a
great education or
some combination thereof or this one is
actually geographically close i like
this person but they're very far and you
know there are different rates and all
of these things um and our feeling was
that we wanted one egg donor meaning you
get a whole bunch of eggs well hopefully
you get a whole bunch of eggs from the
egg donor and then we would take several
you know we'd split the eggs so let's
say you got i think the first time
around we got like 18 eggs
and then you take the sperm we would
split them so now there's like nine and
nine i'm giving you the rough estimates
here um and you would then inseminate
them
and then you hopefully from that some of
it takes some of it doesn't take but
then in essence you have these embryos
and then you need surrogates so the
surrogate obviously is the woman who
then carries the child so basically what
we've got cooking here is that we have
one
baby that is from
my stuff and one baby that is from
david's stuff but they both will have
the same biological mother and we wanted
them to have that sort of genetic
connection and right now there are two
really fantastic women and you know it's
not an easy thing to be a surrogate this
is not something people really do for
money they do it for a higher purpose
for sure and really two absolutely
amazing women are carrying our babies
right now so we have two babies again
one from each of us biologically but
they will be connected through the egg
the genetic material of the mother
one baby will be born in august
and one baby will be born in october so
they are not going to be twins in a in a
technical sense
um but they are
as a as a life going forward i think
they'll be they'll really be thought of
as twins because you know two months
means means nothing and they'll be in
the same grade and all of that stuff
um and you know
one of the things that moved me on this
um if i could just back up for a second
you know i said the thing about how i i
sort of
didn't want kids or i wasn't thinking
about it or whatever and and i was on
tour with jordan
and
i met i wrote a little bit about this
and don't read this book
um
i was on tour with jordan and david even
though we were i think we were in europe
when this was really happening david was
really like you know he really really
wanted kids he saw that vision he felt
it was the the next step for us and all
of that and again i'm just so focused on
my career and
trying to save the world and all of this
stuff but i was just like i'm putting
all of my energy into that i'm just
going in that direction
and david had we had been talking about
it for quite some time but he was really
getting like more and more like we
really should do this and we can you
know be great dads and it's not the most
conventional thing ever but
like it'll be fun and it'll be exciting
and like all the stuff that parents tell
you when they're not complaining about
the kids all the reasons that they tell
you that having kids is good like all of
that stuff and then i'm on tour with
jordan at the same time and one night
jordan was talking about being a parent
and being sort of a fully actualized and
complete human being and he was saying
and he said this many times before that
in essence most people
not everybody but most people on earth
need the experience of being a parent
either a mother or a father
to fully complete the journey and then
you can take that journey a little bit
forward that that sort of completion you
can move that forward to being a
grandparent or maybe if you're lucky
enough a great grandparent but that the
experience of raising a child the
experience of
you know not making it all about you and
having something that's more important
than you and all of that stuff that he
felt that most people
actually need that so there i have david
telling me how he really wants to expand
the family and have kids and i'm on tour
with the guy who's the the you know
preeminent thought leader in the world
talking about why it's so important and
i really did some soul searching and i
was like man like who am i to deny the
person that i love
really what they want what they feel
will expand everything that we're doing
in our lives and then i'm on tour with
this guy i have like i'm being handed
this gift by being able to listen to
this every single night over and over
about how you complete your life and
all of these things or how you make it
as whole as possible let's say
uh and that really was what moved me and
and we started going through the
the process of how to do this and uh i
can assure you that it is it is not
cheap it is definitely easier if you got
a man and a woman involved uh i don't
think we have to do uh you know sixth
grade biology for you but it's a hundred
percent
easier if you can go that route um you
know what was interesting also
was that throughout the the surrogacy
process um you know it was during covet
so our
the day we had to deposit the sperm and
you can all figure out what that is you
go to an office
very clinical office and you go into a
special room
they leave you in there for 10 minutes
you do your thing and then they take
that basically they put it on ice and
then they figure out when they're gonna
you know connect it with the egg so to
speak
anyway it was a few days
after they had announced like kovid was
going crazy and they were going to lock
us down and everything else
and uh we lived in l.a at the time we
lived in the valley and our fertility
doctor was in beverly hills so we had to
go over the hill and now you remember
all that when lockdown was happening and
like the roads were like oddly empty but
then suddenly really packed and
everything just felt crazy and it was
really windy day and basically the
doctor was like look they're telling us
we're gonna close down we don't know
when we're gonna open up we don't know
if we're gonna have nurses here we don't
know you better get us that sperm asap
and we got in the car we drove as fast
as we could over the hill to beverly
hills uh to donate the sperm as we get
out of the car and i just thought this
is like just such a moment i will always
remember in my life i write about this a
little bit and don't burn this country
actually like i will always remember
this like as we're getting out of the
car locked down we think like world war
iii or world war z is starting like the
zombie apocalypse is here we've got to
get the sperm to the doctor to save
human society so people will procreate
and we're going to be okay
we're getting out of the car and then my
phone rings and it's donald trump jr and
i'm like man the world's about 10 the
president's son is calling me and then
i'm on the phone with junior and he's
just asking me like you know what do i
think about lockdowns or something like
that he's just checking in i'm on the
phone with junior walking in it was very
windy there's no one on the streets it's
eerie and then we get to the fertility
clinic and standing outside the door of
the fertility clinic is dennis rodman of
all people dennis rodman yeah dennis
rodman former nba player crazy hair
dennis rodman like cross-dressing dennis
rodman who i loved growing up
and he's just outside the sperm clinic
what dennis rodman was doing outside a
sperm clinic i don't know he had a
skateboard with him anyway we go up
there deposit the sperm and then you
know then because of covid and lockdowns
and everything else
the process of surrogacy became very
slow one of one thing that you'll
probably find very interesting actually
is that the uh the pool of surrogate so
there's not like zillions and zillions
of surrogates out there right because
you really do and i genuinely mean this
you have to be a very special person
to want to carry someone else's child
right like like you are the vessel to
help
uh create life but it but at the end of
the day it's it's someone else's child
um so there's not a ton of surrogates
and over the course of of months where
we were going through covid and
lockdowns and everything else it turned
out that a lot of surrogates i was told
80 of surrogates in the market did not
want to get vaccinated for whatever
reason that is whatever personal reason
they had so then there was a very very
small pool
of surrogates obviously we did not want
to force i certainly was not going to do
that force anyone to uh to get
vaccinated or anything like that i don't
want to get too in into the weeds on on
the science and what we ended up doing
and all that kind of stuff but it just
really made things very complex um as
you may remember um you know there were
a couple miscarriages along the way
which um you know apparently and i'm
sure many of you have heard some version
of this in your own private life
there's been an awful lot of
miscarriages in the last two years
doctors don't know exactly what to chalk
that up to is it is it somehow covert
related is it some how vaccine related
is it somehow stress related of the
world feeling so out of control who
knows uh but long story short uh finally
a couple months back we heard that our
first surrogate was pregnant and a
seriously strong baby like they're
really impressed with this kid the
numbers are off the charts um and then
we were like you know what we just got
to keep moving we got to keep moving you
know i'm 45 years old i'm not getting
any younger i want to be able to play
catch and shoot hoops with this kid i
hurt my hip this last night i don't know
what's going on i was like limping
around this morning like like the clock
is ticking i'm not like uh marissa tomei
in uh
uh what was it what was that movie uh
my cousin vinnie you know like her
biological clock is ticking not quite
like that but like you know we had to
move so once once we knew that the the
first surrogate was pregnant we were
just like let's just keep going because
because who knows you know there there
could be other miscarriages there could
you know just delays like covid could
come back the doctors may want not want
like there's so many things so many
things
um and then we tried again and it worked
so we've got these two
these two babies on the way and uh you
know uh people keep telling me i'm gonna
make a great dad uh we shall see you
know i've got a few more months of of
freedom so we're gonna try to enjoy it
as much as possible but i'm looking
forward to the next chapter um but it is
kind of funny the way
people respond when you tell them
because like we're telling people and
everyone's like oh my god you know
you're gonna make a great dad and then
it's also like you better have fun now
this is it for you you had a hell of a
run 45 years you did it you did whatever
you wanted you were having fun all day
oh yeah drinking your tequila making
your steaks you think you can do
whatever you want you know
all right this is part of life it's part
of life and obviously there's a whole
bunch of goodness and and stuff on the
other side so uh we are we are very
excited um i want to thank all of you
that you know people have been sending
me messages about this thoughts and
trying to give advice on surrogacy and
eggs and
doctors reached out to me and all sorts
of stuff
um so we're uh we're very we're very
excited it's also why you know i when we
decided to do the tour
that i didn't want to go crazy and say
oh i'll be i'll be on tour for five
months right now it's like
we have a limited amount of time before
these babies are here and obviously that
that just changes everything like it
just does so we'll figure out how i can
bounce around and still be able to have
some time at home and and do that kind
of thing um so uh yeah
kids man so maybe i'll have a little
co-host on the show maybe two co-hosts
we'll see what happens um all right so
before we wrap up let me jump into some
uh comments from the locals community
and uh and then right at the end we'll
just throw back to those tour dates one
more time rose says woohoo mazel tov
you're both going to be
fantastic you know one of the things
that i'm kind of worried about is like i
don't know how useful i'm going to be
for the first year let's say like when
when the baby is very very small and
there's a lot of you know there's the
pooping and the crying and the screaming
and then you bring a baby into that it's
a lot you know what i'm saying
see what i did there um
yeah like that first year seems like
sort of nuts but you know fortunately
we've got we've got great grandmothers
great grandmothers not great
grandmothers we've got great
grandmothers around here and and i think
david's sister is going to come down and
help and and by the way we want the
the kids oh i guess i could tell you the
sex i didn't tell you the sex there was
a debate we had an internal debate
should we just let the kids decide
do we let the kids decide the sex the
gender and uh the doctor didn't find
that joke funny i used it on almost
everyone all the time when they would
say well what sex or you know have you
thought about the sex and well we're
gonna let the kid decide nobody in the
fertility world finds that joke funny i
find it funny um but
we are having two boys we are having two
boys um it really had nothing to do with
anything other than we went for the
strongest embryos they really can grade
these things there is a system of grades
almost like almost like eggs like in
your in your fridge like triple a
double a single a and they tell you all
sorts of things and you do genetic
testing and and all sorts of stuff and
we really just wanted the two embryos
that had the strongest chance of
survival i would have been happy if it
was two daughters i would have been
happy if it was
a girl and a boy whatever um but we just
wanted we just wanted happy healthy kids
so we went with what was sort of
genetically the strongest
so yeah it's going to be a lot of dudes
around here
j rosen3 says wowza holy moly now you
need to get another dog for clyde oh man
so one of the things we're doing right
now
is clyde is being retrained right now
because he's been a little nutty since
we've been in florida i think the
lizards and the iguanas and the peacocks
everything's like keeping him on edge
and he's been like a little more jumpy
lately and barking a lot and when people
come to the house he jumps over him so
he's getting retrained because we want
him obviously to be great with the kids
and we when we've brought my nieces and
nephews here uh you know kids don't like
to be mauled by the dog so we're gonna
we're gonna do the best we can on that
front so we got somebody that's uh
training clyde right now and we're
actually all doing it together uh anya
says get a lot of sleep in advance yeah
it's like i don't have crazy bag you
know you see these people that like
they're good-looking people seem like
they've got their [ __ ] together life is
good they've managed to you know go
forward into the world and do it all
right then they have a kid and next
thing you know like their face is like
sliding off their skull and they don't
know where am i what happened what's
going on like you know like that thing
so yeah we gotta get i guess i could use
genusl i guess i could use janya cell
you know if there was only a code
geniusell.com
dave you know slash reuben slash dave
rubin to try one see what happens um
but yeah i will catch up on my sleep i
think we're gonna have a night nurse
at least for the beginning someone who
will be here at night to really help
the babies get on a good sleep schedule
and all that stuff also we're going to
have to kind of line it up because we
have this two-month break between the
august birth and the
october birth we got a lot of things
that we need to figure out but
fortunately we have we have great
families and good network and uh i know
we're gonna have a lot of help and you
know
it's all gonna be good
uh tiger says i know that you will raise
a child who values freedom america
responsibility
and thought yeah i hope so i'm gonna do
everything i can
to do that and do it right and uh not
raise a crazy wokester nut bag that
would be a horrible ending to this story
you know wouldn't that be just terrible
like have you met dave rubin's son
you know like she's
a real folkster you know like that would
just be so terrible so i will have to
work on that how do you make a child
that only will do and act exactly as you
wish we're going to have to figure that
out that's that's an important part of
parenting if i'm not mistaken um
but you know that's also part of this
it's like you know this world is so not
the world is not there's just no doubt
about it and and you see there's all
sorts of studies now where young people
are having kids way way later right like
my grandparents age i think both of my
grandmothers had their first kids at 21
and 20 no i think maybe even 19 and 21
something like that and that's a very
rare thing right now you don't hear of a
lot of young people having kids early
and that changes the dynamic of the
family right we have less great
grandparents now because they sort of
age out it's just because families are
starting later i grew up i had uh i had
two great grandparents um actually i had
a great grandfather longer than i had
grandfathers in a bizarre twist um but
you know as we as we age out and we do
things later you know now people are
having children in their late 20s more
and actually into their even into their
mid-30s and some people even late 30s
like anything is actually possible at
this point
and you can you can put your eggs on ice
and all sorts of stuff
but it does change the way the family
dynamic looks and i get why people are
delaying things the world feels very
unsure people don't feel sure about
their jobs they don't feel sure about
the country and all that and in some
ways that was also
like in a small way i would say it was
why i decided i also wanted to have kids
because it was like this thing whatever
we're going through right now it's like
humans have been through it before
humans are going to go through it again
and you got to keep going on and it's
not just that you have to keep going on
you have to keep making sure there's
more people to go on and fight for the
good things and all those things so i i
felt that
like even though this was very personal
mostly like like literally about my
family um there was there is some
societal element to this you know there
really is and uh i think we can win and
i think we can pave the road for a
better world than perhaps exists at this
very moment um
and i guess my job is now double right i
always say i have nothing better to do
than save the world one all right now i
really better get cracking because why
else would you want to bring kids into a
world that is so screwed up so uh i got
a lot of work to do jeez
clear out my calendar save the world
pave a better world for the children do
it today
uh so anyway i have no doubt that uh you
guys are gonna send us all kinds of nice
messages and things and uh i appreciate
it i can speak on behalf of david i'm
sure we appreciate it and don't worry by
the way the kids are not going to be
named dave and david that's for sure
it's enough of that it's it's i get it
it's very confusing for people we will
give the children their own names they
will not be dave and or david or davey
okay nothing
no ds it's enough it's enough
so anyway thank you for listening today
guys uh i look forward to you know
sharing the updates with you and and
hearing from you and getting advice from
you guys and all of that good stuff and
before
these kids enter
this mortal world uh i am going on tour
to say hi to as many of you as possible
uh let's throw that up one more time so
this is just the first leg of the tour
tickets go on pre-sale tomorrow for
locals members so you can join at
reubenreport.locals.com
and at 10 a.m local time in each uh each
city
you will be able to order tickets and
then friday for the general public april
18th orlando florida april 19th west
palm beach april 20th clear water
florida three floridian stops to get us
going uh april 21st raleigh north
carolina april 22nd atlanta georgia
april 23rd chicago illinois april 24th
dallas texas april 25th washington dc
april 26 west nyack new york uh may 11th
and there's a little break may 11th brea
california may 12th oxnard california
may 15 san jose california
may 16
phoenix arizona may 18th denver colorado
and then yeah we will add some things
yes we're going to get nashville in
there do not worry we're going to get
some more texas stuff maybe i'll go up
to portland and seattle i don't know
we'll we got a debate you know and now
i'm an expecting father so i have to be
a little more careful you know i don't
want to get you know
go to portland
a lot of weirdness there something ain't
right over there
guys you can order pre-order don't burn
this country dave reuben.com book uh you
can get it at your local bookstore all
the links are there you check that out
see
purchase it wherever you're comfortable
purchasing it and if you want to play
along you can join us at room
report.locals.com part one of my
interview with rick grinnell is up right
now on youtube and on rumble the full
things up ad free at locals and uh
thanks everybody i know this show is a
little bit different than usual i guess
there's some kind of war maybe they're
bringing back kovid whatever we'll deal
with all that tomorrow but
for today
having some kids so all right
have a good one everyone see you
tomorrow
you